anyways but going back to it so look the
one part i like how you explained um
the fact that women go through different
phases so do men so you know for myself
i said okay i can see some of that stuff
making sense to some people and i
totally can see that meaning
how men change once they get married how
women change once they get married
and then you know some women are like
well my man is no longer interested in
me like he used to be and some men
are like well you know my girls no
longer my woman is no longer interested
in me like she used to be right so
if if you don't mind going through the
phases we go through so
when i'm 18 years old i'm in the army
you know
what do you have on me you know there's
only one thing on your mind right that's
reading a lot of business books i mean
obviously
i want to read business books math
analysis trigonometry that was a main
outcome of my life at that time i'm
lifting weights i'm fired up i got a lot
of testosterone we're running a bunch of
miles every day and somehow somewhere
you got to release it so 18 to whatever
age
then you get to a point you look at the
market and you say okay
that girl chose that guy over me what
the hell are we talking about here
that guy is a schmuck but he's making
money and he's gonna get over me this
doesn't make any sense and i don't even
like his attitude he's like so you know
okay let me go try to compete in a
different way then you go maybe a little
bit more into career you get focused and
if you do it early on you have the
ability to win but what phases do men go
through and if you can kind of go all
the way through to maybe 50. sure and
what phases do women go through i'd be
really curious okay well it's it's
actually easier for me to start with
women because
the second book is exactly about that i
i pegged it as at a timeline now there
is a very famous graph that i uh
published way back in like 2013 or 2014
it's a it's two bell curves it's when
women are at their peak of their sexual
market value versus when men are at the
peak of their sexual market value and in
in many different ways men and women do
not mature at the same rate okay even
when it comes to like puberty when it
comes to you know like girls mature a
lot faster than boys do and they get to
a point where they're they're uh is that
what you what you're talking about yeah
that's the one i'm talking about right
there so they can see it but go ahead
keep going we're listening so i and i
you know i'll tell you it's funny when i
was writing the essay where i put that
out there i was like this is like in
kind of instinctive to me and then a lot
of people ran me up the flagpole for for
putting this one out there and then over
the course of the last say like almost
10 years now there's been so many data
sets and so many so much research that
backs this up and i almost get chills
thinking how accurate it was when i was
writing it
but what the where i peg women as far as
their their peak sexual market value is
right around 22 or 23 years old that's
when men find women the most attractive
across the board 23 24 23 24 right right
around there so 15 all the way up to 95
that's the age at which men find women
the most attractive
for women finding men attractive it
staggers so statistically speaking women
find men three to seven years
older than they are as more attractive
now there's a difference between arousal
and attraction and a lot of people
sort of mistake this if you ask a woman
what do you find attractive in a man
she's going to tell you all these
long-term security you know traits that
a guy has to have you say what do you
find around what gets you hot about a
guy uh let's see he's got to have you
know v taper he's got to have you know
you know 26 inch guns he's got to have
six-pack abs he's got to have you know a
chiseled jawline that's that's a
difference so um when men get to be
about 36 years old is when i peg them at
being their at their sexual market value
peak because that is assuming the man
makes the most of his potential
is
you know developing himself becoming
something lives up to his burden of
performance let's just say at 36 to 37
somewhere in there that's when he starts
hitting his stride that's the point at
which he has the potential to have the
most of what makes him the most
attractive to women overall so if you
stay on your game you're working out and
you're on top of your business and you
are on you know you have ambition you
have confidence a lot of that takes a
lot longer for men to develop than it
does for women to get to their point of
see of sexual you know marketability and
so uh one of the things we always talk
about in sort of the manosphere or the
red pill communities is that men must
become and women just are so when women
get to the point where it's like they're
at 23 that's when men want them the most
so that's that's number one and must
become become woman women just are huh
so
so does that mean just to stay on that
and i want you to continue so does that
mean
uh uh uh
for a man to increase the market value
wait till at 37 36 37 i don't think
that's what you're saying no no no but
i'm saying that that's going to be the
point at which you will have the
potential to have the most of what will
make you the most attractive that's
based on what that's based on well based
on on physicality also the fact that
women want a man who's older i think on
an instinctive level women want a guy
who has a more maturity has more of a
capability or proven capability to be
the winner that they want to get with
well those guys don't tend to be part of
their own peer group they tend to be the
guys who who are more mature because
they have had longer to i don't know
become partner at the you know law firm
or get become a surgeon or whatever it
is that they find is sort of you know
status wise as high value but also um to
stay on top of their game build
themselves up and have a better judge of
character there's a lot of things like
if you look at the prerequisites that
women have on the most common dating
sites it is this laundry list of he's
got to be funny he's got to be hot he's
got to love his mom he's got to like
puppies he's got to want kids he's got
to what he got you know have ambition
he's got to be confident and just on and
on and on and on for men it's she's got
to be hot she's got to be available
that's pretty much that's pretty much it
and so when you go and you look at the
this uh it's almost like filling out a
job application when you're going on say
like you know tinder when i tinder so
much but like you know online dating
which is the number one way that men and
women find each other today and start
you know start dating so when you have
that as sort of the prerequisite well
women understand that it takes longer
for men to develop into what's going to
make them the most attractive and to
mature into that and as a result that
has to coincide with what they're going
through so when when a woman is between
say 18 and 28 years old that's her peak
window to find the guy that has the most
of what she's going to need in the
future so if you look at it this way a
woman between 18 and 28 years old she's
got about a 10-year window there to
secure what she's going to need as
long-term security for the rest of her
life so that's a that's a lot of
especially today that's a lot of stress
on women right now to find that guy so
would it not stand to reason that
they're going to look for a guy who is
already a winner a turnkey relationship
where she can go and say oh you make a
lot of money you've done a lot with
yourself um yeah i'm ready to you know
ride or die with you or she's going to
have to look for a guy who has the
potential to become that guy when he's
36 37 years old at his peak so women
will go through the phase of what i call
that
i call it the party years i was just
saying that it was it's the it's the
point at which women are sort of like
expl they have the most sexual
selectivity during those years other
people will call it the whole phase
not my words their words um and then
they'll get to a point where it's uh 29
to about 31 years old which is what i
call the epiphany phase and that's when
women go i'm done with the jerks i don't
want to i don't want to have that
anymore i want to do things right i want
to get right with god i want to have a
right relationship and unfortunately in
our western society right now that's
often too late for women at 30-31
well i'm not saying necessarily it's the
wall like they don't look good anymore
they do the wall when we talk about the
wall the wall doesn't begin here it
begins up here it's acknowledging that
they are not as sexually competitive in
the sexual marketplace at 33 as they
were when they were 23. do you think
that applies to today would also
would all the uh uh what do you call it
you know plastic surgery would all be oh
yeah there's ways to forestall that
right sure right yeah but you're saying
that 33 that's 30 29 or 31 that's the
age well the the for most women their 33
year old self could not compete on the
same level in the sexual marketplace as
her 23 year old self so if you enjoyed
this little short segment from the
podcast that we did here's another short
segment to watch or if you want to see
the entire podcast click over here take
care everybody bye
[Music]
you